welcome back
so we're talking about the laplace
transform which is one of my absolute
favorite uh transforms in mathematics so
the laplace transform
you can think of it as a generalization
of the fourier transform
where you can now take the transform of
badly behaved functions that don't decay
to zero
at plus or minus infinity so the laplace
transform in some sense is a weighted
one-sided fourier transform for badly
behaved functions
and what i'm going to do today is walk
you through some of the kind of examples
of things you can do with a laplace
transform
so i mentioned before that we can turn
pdes into odes odes and algebraic
equations and it's useful in control
theory
so right now i'm going to walk you
through how to compute the laplace
transform of
certain types of functions and give you
some examples
okay so probably the most important is
and i'm going to denote the laplace
transform as curly l
of a function f
let's say f of t is going to equal f
bar of s okay that's uh that's how
i'm going to denote this f bar of s is
the laplace transform of some function
of t
and the first property i'm going to show
you is what is the laplace transform
of df dt so if i have the derivative
of my function what happens when i
laplace transform it
and i'm going to remind you because the
laplace transform is so
intimately related to the fourier
transform it's basically
the fourier transform of a modified
version of the function
we're going to recover a lot of our
favorite properties of the fourier
transform with the laplace transform and
this is how we're going to
be able to simplify these equations is
through this property here
okay so the laplace transform of df dt
i'm literally just going to plug that
into this formula down here
and i'm going to get uh that is the
integral from 0 to infinity
of df dt
e to the minus s t and i'm going to
integrate with respect to time
so integral with respect to dt and now
remember our integration by parts we're
going to say that this is
u and this is d
v and so the integration by parts tells
me that the
the definite integral of u dv
is uv minus the definite integral of v
d u so this is going to equal
uv so e to the minus
s t and if this is dv then v
is just f okay so
this is uv and again we have to
integrate at the bounds
zero to infinity minus the definite
integral
zero to infinity of v d
u okay and again v is just f of t
and d u with respect to t is minus s
so i'm gonna my minus s makes this a
plus
s e to the minus s t
dt all right so i'm just gonna slow down
and remind you
the derivative of e to the minus s t
with respect to time is
minus s e to the minus s t
and so that minus uh
integral becomes a plus s integral good
and so i'll just put under braces this
is uh this is u this is v
this is v and this whole thing
is d u d u equals minus
s e to the minus s t good
and so this is actually really really
simple uh
now what i'm gonna do is i'm going to
evaluate so this whole thing on the
right
this integral right here is just the
laplace transform of f
times s so this is just s times
f bar and now i have to evaluate
this definite part this this part here
okay and so this is going to equal
and this is kind of fun e to the minus
st
if i evaluate it at positive at t
equals positive infinity this equals
zero
okay and so this whole thing equals zero
on this bound
and so then it's minus this whole thing
evaluated at zero
so i'm going to get minus e to the
zero which is one f of zero minus
f of zero plus
s times the laplace transform
of f and so that is the laplace
transform of the derivative of a
function
is s times the laplace transform of the
function
minus the initial condition minus that
function evaluated at time
zero okay so
the laplace transform of df dt
equals
the laplace transform of my regular
function minus the initial condition
minus f
at time 0. and this is an absolutely
incredibly
useful formula because it allows me to
take differential equations
and turn them into polynomials in s
so if i had a second derivative of f
with respect to t
this would become an s squared if i had
a third derivative this would become an
x
cubed and so if i have a differential
equation in terms of multiple
higher derivatives of f with respect to
t those all just turn into polynomials
in
s times the laplace transform of regular
f
just f f bar and that's really useful so
we're going to see how to do that
in a little bit good other properties
that are really important so i'm going
to put a star
because that is absolutely really really
important
two stars the other property i'm going
to tell you about
is if i take the laplace transform of
f of t convolution integral
with g of t and i'm going to uh
i'm not going to derive this one because
it takes a little bit of time but this
is exactly like
the fourier transform of convolution so
i'm going to point you to that video
and if i forget to link to it uh just
write in the comments and i will
i will link to it but this is going to
equal
the product of the laplace transform of
f
regular product times the laplace
transform
of g so it's going to equal f
bar of s times g bar
of s and this is really nice because
convolution integrals are generally hard
to compute
this is just the product of two
functions in the laplace domain
so if i have a convolution integral i
just laplace transform and i get the
product
of the individual laplace transform of f
and the laplace transform of g
and this is really useful in control
theory so this is how we handle transfer
functions in control theory
so this is another very very useful
property
that we're going to use all the time in
solving pdes and control theory are
really kind of these two
big properties okay good uh and i will
show you how to do some of those
properties
how to use those for pd's and odes uh in
in the next video i think now what i'm
gonna do is i'm just gonna walk you
through some kind of homework examples
like
compute the laplace transform of this
function or that function
because a lot of you have asked me for
those kinds of problems in the past
okay before i do that i want to point
out a couple of fun facts about laplace
one of my absolute favorite
mathematicians
pierre simone laplace
he was one of the he provided
perhaps the first satisfactory
explanation
of why the planets in the solar system
are stable and don't fling off to
infinity
so after kind of kepler and newton and
galileo
that was still a big open problem is
even if we know f equals ma
and the physics how do all of the
planets actually stay in stable orbits
together
that was first satisfactorily explained
by laplace which i think is really
interesting
he also posited gravitational collapse
which is kind of the
predecessor of our idea of black holes
and he was also one of napoleon's
examiners
actually i think this one's kind of fun
a lot of laplace's writings
he would write if there was some
derivation that was long and ugly
sometimes he would just write it is easy
to see that dot
dot and he would bypass all of that
heavy math and so he kind of
was one of the original mathematicians
that said you know it's obvious that or
it's clear that or it's trivial that and
so i think that's kind of fun
okay good so let's do a couple of quick
examples here
uh the first one i'm going to do is i'm
literally just going to take the laplace
transform
what if f of t was equal to one
okay so what we're going to do is we're
going to take the laplace transform of
this function and i'm going to convince
you that it's really easy to do
so f bar of s is equal to the integral
from 0 to infinity
of 1 times e to the minus
st dt really easy what's the integral of
e to the minus st with respect to time
well with respect to time s is just a
constant
and so i get minus 1 over s uh
yeah minus 1 over s e to the minus st
that's that's the integral of e to the
minus st but remember this is a definite
integral
and so now i have to evaluate this at
zero and infinity
okay and again at t equals infinity
this whole thing is zero so this equals
zero
minus minus one over
s e to the minus s times zero
because now i evaluate at t equals zero
and e to the zero is one
so this equals minus of minus is plus
one
over s so one over s
this function here one over s is the
laplace transform of the constant one
these are laplace transform pairs and
it's that easy
that's how easy it is to compute the
laplace transform of a function
you just take that function plug it in
and crank through the integral
and a lot of us you know we've spent a
lot of time getting really good at these
kinds of integrals
so this is kind of fun uh when you when
you do this okay
um good what's another example another
example would be
let's say f of t maybe i'll do
a slightly different color i'll do blue
let's say f of t
equals e to the
what is it e to the uh
i'm just gonna look at my notes yeah
okay if it's e to the a t
so we see these functions all the time
as solutions of odes pd's
and in control theory these this is e to
the a t is the basic solution
of a linear system of differential
equations so we might want a laplace
transform that
so the laplace transform of e to the a t
again i'm going to just go through
and say f bar of s equals integral 0 to
infinity
of e to the a t times e to the minus
st dt i can combine those exponentials
and i get
e to the a minus s
t dt again need to keep my definite
integral
that is going to equal one over a minus
s e to the a minus
s t and this whole thing is going to be
evaluated at the bounds of integration
from zero to infinity
okay and so now i'm gonna again uh
if i plug in t equals infinity or t
equals zero i'm gonna get different uh
answers here
and so i'm going to say that again if i
plug in positive infinity
we assumed that we've multiplied this
thing by a stable enough
e to the gamma t that this decays to 0
at positive infinity
so this is going to be 0
minus 1 over a minus
s e to the a minus s
evaluated at t equals zero okay
and so i get minus minus this is one
over s
minus a so again the laplace transform
of e to the a t
is just 1 over s minus a and in control
theory
those of you who have studied control
theory know that this is
a simple transfer function with a pole
at s equals a that is the same thing as
saying that my differential equation
that generated this
had an eigenvalue of a and so it's
really really easy to compute
the laplace transform of simple
functions using this formula here
and you could do the laplace transform
of cosine
of sine of the heavy side function of
all kinds of different functions
and you would get nice easy to interpret
solutions just by cranking through the
integral
now it turns out that the inverse
laplace transform can be kind of
hairy okay so this inverse laplace
transform
you usually need to use complex uh
integral theory
or complex analysis to compute these
integrals so
inverse laplace transforming this is
much more complicated than doing the
the forward or direct laplace transform
you need things like bromwich integrals
uh which sound delicious but are not and
uh so usually i give the examples of
doing forward laplace transforms
because the inverse laplace transform is
pretty hairy okay
good uh so let's just summarize the
laplace transform
invented by pierre simone laplace
is a generalization of the fourier
transform it basically allows you to
take fourier transforms of nasty
ill-behaved
functions by it's like a one-sided
weighted fourier transform given by this
but it has a lot of the same properties
so uh the laplace transform of
derivatives
is just the laplace variable times the
laplace transform of the
regular function without taking the
derivative minus the initial condition
so the fourier transform
formula for a derivative looks a lot
like this but the laplace transform has
this initial condition
minus f naught and that's going to be
really important when we solve odes
and pdes using the laplace transform you
also get the same
convolution integral formula and it's
really easy to take the laplace
transform of our favorite
functions okay so next time i'm going to
show you how to
simplify odes by using this property
here
and turning them into algebraic
functions all right thank you